Так я гадаю ти з України Охренеть
пощастило галявині Чому
Я зараз вам покажу українську
біолабораторії шановні друзі гарматне
м'ясо зубні плани Путіна щоб
кров його стала смолою падла щоб його
перед ними було мої будуть його як млинець
здох російський військовий корабель
[музика]
Привіт привіт
з професійності ще й із собою
проніс 2022 Ірік що з таки у свиті
покращується на порушення А саме пітбатя
Піцу до євроку в Тім я
середньостатистичний мешканець скажемо
азахіною Європи загадувати MFC 12 місіс
євроку годину кожного українця з бузовася
до 10 проти трава вина Русі проти
України
отож Ми вирішили
нашу Україну з моменту 24 лютого Алла
півняним ракурсом ми розповімо вам
через меми наша команда забрала їх
вторгнення та сама мами
стало розлучення Ками українці виявив Іса б
на всіх мозкових фронтах адже
середньому вископуху вулкарського
дипломатичного і аж креативного ось
такий кількусті-жартів і майміїв з
протукував український народ небачив
адже на юспішній сезоні на граючих
командійних шоу а парший мем вінджа
символ українського попиту
24 лютого як бичок зараз загадує
пишність це продовжувати не в тому над
донати
Що таке побожність військовому
кораблейному для шкірного росіян вона
напрямі на Єви підкований російський військовий
корабель
Може
у матрицю шкірного українці
напівпершим куркач яйця Мені потрібно щось
сказати
факт завищується фактом ті українці та
кіно помістився до скроні матерів він
впоралася з цим тлом і гострим і
мовами та показала окупантам знамену
української
третій танк інакше постаралася у міліції
викручували по вирізали Саша можна
Охренеть
не покидаєте нас
добре Слава Україні
[оплески]
своєї землі встають на тільки українці.
і сама Наша мама
Ага все зрозуміло різні вітається Скажи
слово Поляни то А чого вона знімати
хтось мені сказав що відеозйомка
заборонено
Конституцію України
відеозйомка дозволено До спец педрість
справі ворога стою насправді
спецпризначенці залізла
а блакитну всім розвинути загоном генерал
полінуватися
винна Льоша право виявляючи ворога Алей
ви клацаєте насправжні замикання в головах
російських пропагандистів
полиці Україна чекала на всю колоду
допоможу видзахідних партнерів головним
пусточальником техніки для ЗСУ стала
сама друга армія свиту запас редницького
господареві цього українського солянства
[музика]
наші тягнуть битр до дому у двір
буде
запарники другий місяць провини Російська
армія витрачала меншвискові збитки
нижче за годину провини в Афганістані у двох
чеченських винах та простим жителям було
їх прийшов довідник гори Ти кого ніхто
їх мирних
чому це заборонили ліптону Я що буду
харчуватися
ні Макдональдса це [ __ ] якщо ми до
досі думаєте що для мене як для
блогера інстаграм це джерело заробітку
ви глибоко помиляєтесь
це просто це все життя це душа
[музика]
Домінос Бургер Кінг Макдональд скоро
ханіку
[музика]
скорботний плач жителі у Росії за
зваби ми злочинного заходу прокинувши
всієї один з головних постучальників у
нами в українському Інформ просторі
піднімається над головкою ось так
затискається щоб не травмувати голівку
Давайте герметик
цей Божественний А я зараз вам покажу
у його викравінеральності гвинт
законообраний президент України
напала на його Велику та могутню Імперію
ворожнечі яхту
один із лідерів
точно знав
зараз вам покажу А я зараз вам покажу
А я зараз вам покажу звідки на Білорусь
готовність випадання І якби за 6
годин до операції не було нанесено
превентивний удар по позиціях чотири
позиція зараз покажу карту привіз вони
б атакували Наші війська Білорусії
Росії які були на навчанні тому не
ми розв'язали цю війну у нас совість
чиста добре що почали
вам покажу
напад якого
ми розв'язали цю війну А я зараз вам
покажу, звідки на білорус готувалася
напад весна Україна з лічильника на
виток новицького в Портнов за таких
умів з аварію за поребрикових
пропагандистів по всій Україні
відкриваються біолабораторії
українські біолабораторії запровадили
дослідження перенесення бойових вірусів
птахами з 2009 року
[музика]
бойовик гуси та Диверсанти Уті
розробки в лабораторіях проходові
транування за раз на натовських базах як
раз самій повертаються буяк же Тріска я сни
цією тратою і видству росіян з пилися і
сирівщини
у сонячному про Чорному морі починається
улюблений усіма українцями серіал
чорнобаївка
сюжетний вибагловий Зате Яг загріваючи
серце на посадку квитня наростіть запала
Москва Натиснули на ту якубачив у своїх
наїсу кращих снах українці а то й так і
військовий корабель екаїзу хесняк острова
зміїний вид право у відомому всім
напрямі
[музика]
так Рівна через 110 Роккі якщо Титаніка
і вперше в іншу світловий Флагман
російського флоту став найбільшим
скроневим кораблем затопленим пити
Наразі ризикового конфлікту освоївся
нахабним за легендами дві українські
ракети романтичні названі
версії Європейського коридорства
буває в Україні залишилося від ідейкули
служба в Іспанії України в пімало рідкісних
снуптаху Яків Тим не змогла доробити це
ще до піввенд Дніпра і подала від пивів
шлях до свого кума Віктором адвенчука
[музика]
вершини мої старості ніхто
броник
Вона реально пройшла
проводи бляха реально капець так що їх
не хованки піджинав із крадіжок назви
для владної України це українська
історії про РП писате і не владні їх
несла мені начатки виявився куди
найскромнішим у своїх життєвих заходах
демілітаризуючий туалети шухляди з
цуценя білі та супермаркети
[музика]
[оплески]
історія з броником
ось
так завоювати
кілька Ти ж невинні бражки
сформували у свідомості українців та
почет образ страшного екіпірованого з
їх до голови правого солдата інший
армії на вигляд
виступає
російського солдата на весь годинник
[музика]
ну нас промившись захлопи такі труднощі
і блажуватий парадних роздрукував Росії
вдалося йому сором це все Україні
обстрілу ми всі наші території та
область що ось цю куротію і для Перемога
без традиційно на чоловічий
[оплески]
це мерзота
командир Танкістів
дотаєва Риму саліховна по Червоній
площі проходить Парадний розрахунок першої
Гвардійський червонопрапорний танковий
армії
вітає танкову колону Майор Олег
Мамонтів у складі колони сучасні
покоління Російської бронетехніки
[музика]
[оплески]
Стефані та мама Муня Стефанія
Стефанія
[музика]
балону
так українці назвав це, що самі росіян
з усіх каналів та мануали клуб Ками
будеш слово вибух я йду тільки слово
Війна прийшла у статус за буронами
інших опуклий
буйну на заводах
бавовна бавовна бавовна бавовна пролунала в 7
ранку будуть бавовни після овації
переходять у бурхливі Оплески
товариші
[музика]
Давайте піднімусь Я кажу Москві осі
такі клуби чорного диму заразом зараз
був підпали 8
я клюди метушився пожежі приїжджають люди
у шоці очі вилазять У них Ну а мені
тепло приколу
бігають метушаться намагаються руками згасити
а він уже
[музика]
знанням літа в Україні вставала до Сага
гречіші росіяни не здати не закупівлю
вид території бджоли масовий обстріл
український нафтобаз я до результату
дефіцит бензино тановий сплавка кретова
вид України
[музика]
тільки зараз повним боком бензика
з України
[музика]
видно українців до міжнародних за них
шматочки почету зазвучав Сто один росіян
протаїк вашу імбирним стрижити так ваш
починають Москва ти себе перед українцями
[музика]
Великобританії всі розуміють і в Україні
від
рибальський Куна допоможу треба нас прибула
Ну ж секрет нас брови
[музика]
апоканімається до політичної еліти
вагається в Україні на вигляд і розуміють
пропан краще свої стратегії нібито
не придумали росіяни не придумала видно
і так вони прийдуть у
покаркам і братові, і жертви, і все, а потім
ми їх усіх бомбуємо немає в абхаєм
Туреччину нормально
[музика]
ось таку саме ганчірку статеву у нас у
місті вирішила вона нам Тут треба зняли
по-чоловічому на салі на її принципі вона
тільки для цього і придатна і кудись геть
туди Її Треба викинути полетіла
куполи на території України Не
забувайте, що вона дихнувшись чоловік нести
українських скроневих і навіть пілітків
шизоїках іншим Алла Еммануель макрон
Олаф шорльз тамаріо драги так і
проїжджають до України аби на владу не
дуже побачите такі російський світ так от
що ти вже традину для глуху українців
музику
[музика]
тим часом на Русі дефіцит західного
фастфуду у російському організмі ТАСС
формовані історично-стрілецьких Горобців
вибирання нашого сусіда будь усім
статут це крабку виробляють донародження
нового покрочу такого особини косплея на
Макдональдс смачно і точка Але ви не
відсоток йде владні здобутки в шини
рональда макдональда Таро приховують для
американців новогрань російського
плагіату Вчора стало відомим
Макдональдсе відкрилася наново на Росію
з новим ребрендингом до нових м'ян
смачного та CSS
он ідисно хоче виножуватість
весняного бренду Макдональдс зняти їх
нову рекламу якщо Ти фанат подумав що
тобі сподобається чи ти зможеш витерпіти
смачну та точку Ми пропонуємо багато
знайомих позицій з меню таких я шматок
кілограмового бург розмолочним
квадратом картопляна стружка кімнатна
температури смажені пташині кубики
Якщо ви побачите зниклого клоуна
рональда макдональда дзвоніть у поліцію
смачно
любить батька чоловік можна задати Так можна
тільки Будь ласка швидше тут був по
справам вас на сьогодні план справи
спочатку треба зазирнути в незручна
крапка там дивани але я не дуже подобається
у них пружини в дупі постійно
застряє Ну потім треба за продуктами
з'їздити в що дали то їж і крапка потім
потрібно заглянути до улюбленого магазину дружини
знайти що є нахуй крапка потім потрібно
заскочити швиденько завалити свою з
під нігтів бруд ебана і точка не знаю
навіщо було Джек перейменовувати і
увечері думаю можна на вечерю з дітьми у
смачна точка заглянути я відповів
велике спасибі
вийшов коннейросійський плагіат сагая
свого
українські та саму і даю України росіян
та починають фарби українські пісні
[музика]
Спи собі сама
коли в тебе немає мене
за кільками сітки Україна Кіль
корзіїв стрибала світ скроневу
вправністю стікею прямого і на
культурному фронті А ви так щоб за
Трейду бути і брата мільйони на 4
замість трьох запланованих
байеракторії такого і самі вирівняється
їх безпілотних чиколи фонди Сергія
Притулки розумів та України живим
вимагатимуть на боєкомий вигляд українців А з
броні України потроюють
налисо-байрактари якийсь ворожий над
адже втрачена та я без Кущів
[музика]
падінням економіка на тлі війни по чали
з барикати свої груші у банках
нададуть фінанси експерти не повинен один
анатомити Костя і остя дужі на бо
пориві на цех двох банках лежати Міньйони
гривою без ніша їх конвертично трьох
пташок
і планети ще пересоли ти туди все
хрузках А Боже на бетоні щоб
забуруватий на заводи московські деталі А
для того, щоб смерть російської купанчі
в Жора донаті на три байратари для зсу
та притулку що всьому Gucci Ванька у
марла та коліна
якщо
я з ним в Інстаграм я їх завивав будук
Стендап чи то рахунок
а ви і наш заросла година в Росії
довбоєбнувся вид образ Бір
просто скінганат Скільки можеш
[музика]
результатам владного лиха прийшла
України британський прем'єр Джонсон у
Україні
нашим особливим Робін гудом українських
[музика]
Добридень
Слава Україні
що дали Росія провалювалася у при рові
фейкових
немов новий запас російських
пропагандистів дикої зірки українських
бульбашок поповнила все стихію слово з
покращенням жест доброї волі
Збройні сили Російської Федерації
[музика]
тому що отримали [ __ ] ось і все
це можна дивитися вічно
так і без відсотків
по-своєму і продемонстрували владні
урозуміння новим ставленим всемогуртню
гіда
О Боже
ти нічого сам одна заводну в Україну
мабуть пробувати пускові ракетні
установки хаймар де кипіткривав і
пародокупантами Поклик земноїуральності
їхнього перебування на Сонячній
українські землі
каші
[оплески]
[музика]
гриби ока втомимося годиною українці з
підстригає вже ті кого тенденцію ще
раніше генерального штабу фірвала цифра
ранку сиру 150 200 Осип за раз 500-600
з чимось пов'язок у нас пофарбувалась estem
вигляд у чеки нічого
[оплески]
[музика]
[сміх]
Що таке ти все до самого Криму?
курортний сезон на першоострові, що його
ганебні росіян і проводив цей 8
репоспель для багатюхизних деспотивону
інших слову кінця Сирі Які звуки
видають свої Миколи їх заганяють до Себа в
хліб
взагалі не хочу їхати
не хочу я змушена виїжджати зі своїми
дітьми збирати
Так я звикла Тут як
у своєму будинку жили настільки
по домашньому вам Полтавський галушки
нібито по-домашньому а Московську
ковбаску риза ти взагалі не хочу вам тут
я заголомок
[музика]
мамуля Мамуля Звалюй звідси
Ти жила в алушки
[музика]
президента Олексій арештович про
рукомаї закиньшита севейна розстебнувся
на місяць
українців просто владних дружині хто ж
ендокрі хто і заарештуєш Якова на
підшадку винни називав справним
залякувальним та мотиватором кусачку
драйвел знаєте що вас дівчата дуже
люблять
я певним чином фахівець з
агентам МРТ
ясновидець Знахар Ведун цілитель
Магістр Бурштинової зірки та маг
єдиний представник діамантової
раси на землі Алмаз може і там на
шопіться я вловлюю ультразвуки Бачі в
посилання вийти читаю мислиновидцями
вгору на 20 метрів за дружину на 50
може придбати будь-який залити за і
подряпати будь-яку камінь А за один раз
може бути
сказано ще продовжувати
вам так не буде
саме цього сезону слабко жінці з
пророків праворуч небо Соні в українців
відживши Сіми боялася заснути і пропусти
тину вистрибнути
словом і тампами витісняє купаньки в
садаль і Далі схит скроні експорти
назвав це яво ще каскадним обвалом
фронту російський пропагандисти
парагрупу ванні а самі українці
[музика]
набрали повітря і за моєю командою щодо
три рази два три
[оплески]
місяця винні курси вибралася через
кіншита видався
та деміліталізація України закликали до
мобілізації на самих Росії шановні
друзі
[музика]
і ядерний Шантаж вбивають людей кидають у
в'язницю зводять рахунки розправляються
знущаються над нервові громадяни ми і
зараз це зробимо так і буде змогли
розколоти Радянський Союз А зараз прийшло
час і самої Росії
[музика]
привіт Андрій
Господи благослови Сполучені Штати
Рашка [ __ ] жиги тільки не іржати Джон
дівчат матерів просіть прокладки
чоботи найдешевші прокладки плюс
найдешевші тампони кульове поранення
Прям туди вводите і все починає
розбухати і придавлювати стінки чоловіки я
це зараз не знаю я не розумію як
можна жити в цій країні та не довіряти
цій державі найголовніше не
довіряти і не вірити в наших пацанів
що незграбні розумний красень
[сміх]
[оплески]
коза
ми зараз знаходимося
Білгородської області
нас у районі 500 осіб
зі зброєю, але при цьому ми не приписані
Абсолютно ніякої частини
тиждень ми прожили в скотських умовах
ніякого матеріального забезпечення
грошового забезпечення
нічого
раптом хто не знав на війні взагалі
загалом люди ось як зробити максимально
небезпечного воїна, який [ __ ] не вміє
беремо простого селянина який
взагалі нічого не вміє і ми його навчаємо
працювати з списом Там два тижні Все
відправляємо на війну
будь-якого елітного бійця лицаря який
10-15 років тренувався просто селянин
довге списом
Бувай
нікому не потрібні підготовки рівним рахунком
0 ми живемо
а
[музика]
ти просто ви підтримаєте мобілізацію в
Росії так Звичайно країна вона
створена щоб захищати цю Батьківщину
звичайно підтримуємо Звичайно ви теж
будете защищать Ні я нема ось так по
стану здоров'я Ну поки
піднемобілізований призів дула особисто і
каламутної армії інчі я до їх члени встик
весь кумат ви вирішили проживати за частку
бути члени будь-які на відстоні
[музика]
Ну, все тепер мені точно
слухайте
[музика]
казкові тварюки не будьте як вдома вам
тут офіційно не радіє це факт це мій
будинок тому Будь ласкав Заходь у нього з
добрими намірами або Іди на апок з
Росії ріком випливала живописного сина
в Україну напорталася На восьмому
місяці провини та на 69-му роті звільнити
тебе Віктор Медведчук лікар з того
нагоді Україні його обміняли на 215 у
Маріуполі вчора відбувся черговий
обмін полоненими між Росією та Україною
Україна отримала 215 своїх військових у тому
числі до крайності демонізованих
азовців які захищали Азов сталь в
Маріуполі їхні командири яких Росія
обіцяла ніколи не змінювати та Розстріляти
тепер також на волі в Росії вже
повернули 55 російських військових і
кума Путіна Віктора медведчука якого
російська влада також раніше вона
захищали не міняти на азовців
[музика]
холодало маразм у бункері міц ніша
Росія вирішила волосся цієї території
дональського Луганської Херсонської це за
Паризької області жадібно за яких не
змогла укупуватий повністю територією
РФ запропоновану ініціативу під куполи
инчхи європейської України А краще мус
Росія
ентузіазмом участь в історичному
референдумі прийняв і самий світлий
князь Григорій Олександрович
потьомки-таврійський державний
діяч творець Чорноморського військового
флоту та його першої головно начальницький
генерал фельдмаршал саме він заснував
Катерина Слав Херсон Севастополь
Миколаїв А в 1784 році будучи
генерал-губернатором новоросії славний
місто Мелітополь ми з матінкою
а а референдум
дорогі жителі Російської Федерації
настав час з 23 по 27 вересня ми
проводимо референдум у якому ви можете
голосувати за приєднання Голландії Ну
це звичайно хочете
Перестаньте слухати брехні Путіна
приховує від вас що історична Росія
належить до нідерландів настало
час об'єднатися наш король Вільям 4
теж ваш король
1816 Алла Павлівна 1 вийшла заміж за
Вільям 2
Ну та він погано говорить російською
і нічого впораємося
своїм королем на здоров'я і це ж не
випадково, що Рідна дочка Путіна роками
вже живе
повірте там за кайфом ніхто не живе
тільки за свою справжню батьківщину Кремль
більше від вас приховує у Горбачова
зовсім не було жодної родимки це була
татуювання Голландії Ну і у нас прапор
майже однакові тут просто потрібно білу
частина вниз Ні білу частину між Ой немає
це фермери перевернути так Ось бачите
Урал названий у частину фестивалю
відбувається
додаткова Вигода Якщо ви
приєднайтесь Голландії ваші сини не
помиратимуть у безглуздій війні
проти України
голосувати можете онлайн через мене
хочеться Голландії точка ру
[музика]
Калінінградську область Росії яка
знаходиться між Литвою та Польщею може
забрати собі Чехію вже повідомляється що
якщо там провести референдум, то 97
відсотків жителів виявили б бажання
приєднатися до Чехії зараз у Чехії
навіть створено спеціальний сайт який
присвячений кралу в цу в якій буде
перейменований Калінінград прямо на сайті
написано що кралівець тобто
Калінінград знаходиться в Чехії після
успішного референдуму 97 відсотків
мешканців Калінінграда вирішили
приєднатися до Чехії та перейменувати
Калінінград у краловиці жителі
Калінінградської області могли б
попросити Чехію ввести війська щоб
встановити там демократичну владу та
закінчити російську гегемонію вона
чеському сайті петицій з'явилася петиція
автори якої вимагають приєднання
російського екс-клава до Чехії як
підстави для приєднання наводиться
історичний факт, що місто кенігсберг
був заснований чеським королем прожимислом
атакарем другим петиції вже підписала
більше 13 100 тисяч осіб у ній
зазначено, що Росія своїми діями в
Україні автоматично дозволила вести
війська в Калінінград і провести там
референдум про приєднання до Чехії
[музика]
до дня народження Великого
Україна підготувала підрунок
розвінчування міфу про
невідомість Кримського мосту
ми всіх українців
українці відомо що за пропанував і
свої варіанти поїхали
Стефані та мама монети
Це загроза я враховують
рівень захисту мосту підвищує
так добре захищена так підвищується
рівень захисту а потім мостом їдуть вже
відразу
всі відпочиваючі які приїхали
потім уявити, що буде завдано
такий
кинувся там машини з нього потрапляє це
розряду фантастики
ми розуміємо це може бути ракета це
можливо машина це може бути судно
які там проходить кримським мостом або
там знаходиться
землетрусам 9
можна зруйнувати якимось снарядом
[музика]
і написав нам так уже Володимир побіг 7
недопалку ніби ростертом без останку слова
засунув
щоб
кров'ю стало смолою падлу щоб його
значення
та демонстрацію
[музика]
ядерним ударом светра десивного все
українці традиційно ви вирішили зустріти
[музика]
[оплески]
у Team сказати що українців нічого не
зможе По справедливому за чіпи ти брехали
хвилі завданнями правда що таки дис
але виплакав довідник і зани покоління
[музика]
нормально супер
Ми скоро поїдемо Херсон, а потім здобудемо.
травень це біомечаю забуду Наш Крим івент
більше Миколи не стоятиме
[музика]
українцям нас тут завдали всі пісні
Херсона лікар залишилася ця Україна
окупанти тут
[музика]
взагалі не хочу їхати
по-домашньому
[музика]
шевард тут здавалося що дедпул знову
браузер все розлюбився і ви вирішивши, що я
нічого не можемо дієти через такі
з простим та українцями
світло води та тепла так Україна знову
понилася Віднови реальності графіки
електроенергії за Здрасте сусідами та все
така творчість
[музика]
у кафе на районі
два Значить
немає доступу до
гріховних сайтів і до розпусних Кім
Я поважаю тебе плюс
[музика]
літера А зупиніться
літера я
літера про
млинець не дадуть у темряві згущеного молока
нажертися літературі
[музика]
Давай вимкнемо світло Нехай так у продажів
2022 року уроку Україна протестує
російську вискорено без прецеденту
не брехни сміливо його до метлуєва саму
видану з гумару чарлики показували нашу
силу тоядність а вони вся сила їде і
адже шайдушніше серця українців у свою
чергу надихають
свитці дух України люди на руку за
версію видання тайм але обкладайте
журналу портрет президента та відомих
українців
[музика]
Що таке наче сміливим Як Україна
випробує ви але бути шкірян України з
матом і свою відповідь весь кову в
улунтарську виводжу на дипломатичні шини
розвалову хуліганську А ми командою
ukrainor скажемо ще українською сміливими
зі сміливістю ніби людиною забуде їх
обставон зі Свобода про аборати люди
нести і мати за хисноків з людським
новим роком Україну та хайвенгуду роком
парамої
[музика]